joelle has two after-school jobs
babysitting and working at her parents
grocery store working at the grocery
pays her 12 dollars an hour and
babysitting pays her 9.50 an hour last
week she worked 19 hours in total that
looks like a statement that could lead
to an equation last week she worked 19
hours in total and she earned 56 dollars
more at the grocery store than she did
babysitting that looks like another
statement that could be an equation she
earned 56 more dollars at the grocery
store than she did babysitting and then
they asked us how many hours did she
work at each job
so they want to know so let's define
let's define some variables here
let's define time
babysitting so t sub b as equal to hours
babysitting
hours babysitting
baby
babysitting
and let's define t sub g as hours at the
grocery
hours
at
at the grocery
hours at the grocery so they want to
they want us to figure out what was t
sub b and t sub g what were the hours of
the babysitting and what were the hours
of the grocery now they tell us that she
worked 19 hours total so that blue
statement says that the sum of these two
is going to be 19. so the time she
worked babysitting plus the time she
worked at the grocery store is going to
be equal to
19 19 hours now the other statement this
by itself obviously we can't solve for
these we need another constraint they
said that she earned 56 dollars more at
the grocery store than she did
babysitting so let me define two more
variables here so this is the pay
babysitting this is the pay
babysitting her total pay
babysitting
and let's say p sub g is equal to the
pay
at the grocery store
now what is what are these terms i mean
if we just look at this second statement
right there well to say okay the pay at
babysitting she earned 56 more at the
grocery than she did babysitting so this
second statement tells us that well i
guess the pay
let me write it over here the pay
babysitting she earned 56 dollars more
at the grocery than she did babysitting
so if we take babysitting and add 56
dollars that will get us to how much she
earned at the grocery store that's what
that second statement is telling us 56
dollars more at the grocery than
babysitting so if you add these two you
get the grocery now this still isn't
cool we have
one two
three four unknowns and only two
equations that's not going to help us
but what will help us is we can express
these two variables in terms of these
two variables and then we have two
equations with two unknowns and we can
solve them the way we've solved all
systems of equations now the other
information they give us is the rate how
much she earned per hour working at the
grocery she makes 12 dollars per hour
babysitting she makes 9.50 per hour so
what is going to be her pay babysitting
let me write this over here her pay
babysitting i'll do it in this color her
pay
her pay babysitting
pay babysitting is going to be equal to
the time babysitting
right the time babysitting times how
much she gets paid per hour the time
babysitting is how many hours times how
much she gets paid per hour it tells us
right there she gets paid 9.50 per hour
babysitting
so times
so times 9.50 that is what her pay
babysitting is and then with the same
argument what's her pay working at the
grocery store
her total pay working at the grocery
store
her pay at the grocery is going to be
equal to the time at the grocery the
time of the grocery times the rate that
she gets paid at the grocery 12 dollars
per hour so times 12 dollars per hour
and this hopefully is intuitive if i
worked if i'm making 12 dollars per hour
and i work for i don't know three hours
i'm going to make 36 dollars i would
just multiply these two if i worked two
hours at 950 i'm going to make 19 that's
all this is the total pay so now we can
take these two expressions we could take
this expression and this expression and
substitute it back into that equation
right there and then we'll have an
equation that's only in terms of the
time babysitting and the time at the
grocery store so let's do that so this
first term right here
her total pay babysitting that is this
expression right there so let me write
it right here so 950 times the time
babysitting so i'll just write 9.5
times time babysitting that's this term
right here plus 56
plus 56
is equal to the pay that she got at the
grocery which is 12 times the time of
the grocery which is 12
times the time at the grocery and now we
need to solve for both of these
variables we have two equations in two
unknowns this is just straightforward
algebra at this point
so let's do it so the easiest way to do
this might just be to do straight up
substitution because we have all these
crazy numbers here let's just solve for
the time at the babysitting in terms of
the time at the grocery so if you take
that
if you take this equation this top
equation let me write it over here
so the time
babysitting plus the time at the grocery
is equal to 19. if you subtract the time
at the grocery from both sides
subtract time at the grocery on both
sides you get the time babysitting is
equal to these cancel out 19 minus the
time at the grocery so we solved for the
time babysitting in terms of the time of
the grocery so everywhere we see the
time babysitting
we can substitute it with
this expression right here that's what t
sub b is that is what the time
babysitting is so let's do that so this
equation becomes
9.5 times the time babysitting which we
just figured out from this top equation
is 19 minus the time at the grocery plus
plus 56 is equal to 12 times the time at
the grocery and now we just have to
solve for the time at the grocery so 9.5
times 19
9.5 times 19. that's a little bit of a
hairy let me just do it over here
in on the right side right here so if i
have
times 9.5
5 times 9 is 45
1 times 5 is 5 plus 4
is 9
and then we have a 0 here 9 times 9 is
9 times one is nine plus eight is
seventeen
seventeen so five plus zero is five nine
plus one is ten
one plus seven is eight you just have a
one there and you have one number behind
the decimal point so it's a hundred and
eighty five so 9.5 times 19 is 180 180.5
minus 9.5 times the time at the grocery
minus 9.5 times the time of the grocery
plus 56 is equal to 12 times the time at
the grocery now what's 185 180.5
plus 56 so 180 plus 50 let's add just
those two terms 180.5 plus 56 just to
simplify it 180 plus 50 would be 230 so
this will be 236.5
236.5
minus
minus 9.5 times the time at the grocery
is equal to 12 times the time of the
grocery now we can add the time at the
grocery to both sides of this equation
or the 9.5 so let's do that plus 9.5
times the time at their grocery it is
equal
or plus
plus 9.5 times time at grocery just
adding it to both sides of that equation
and we are left with the left-hand side
that cancels out we just have 236.5
is equal to 12 plus 9 is 21 so this is
going to be 21.5 it's equal to 21.5
times the time she spent at the grocery
so now we can just divide both sides of
this equation by 21.5 and we figured out
how long she spent at the grocery
so let's do that divide both sides by
21.5
so that cancels out the time she spent
at the grocery is going to be equal to
that thing and let's see what that is we
get 21
21.5
goes into
236.5 let's multiply both of these
numbers by 10. so this is the same thing
as 215 going into 2365.
decimal goes right there 215 goes into
236 one time 1 times 215 is 215
and then we can subtract let me scroll
down more this problem is heavier than i
thought it would be
so 36 minus 15 is 21 so 21 bring down
the 5 and lucky for us that's pretty
straight forward 215 goes into 215 one
time 1 times 215 is 215. subtract you
get no remainder so the time at the
grocery store is 11 or 11 hours
now we can go and substitute back to
figure out her time babysitting we know
that the time babysitting is equal to 19
minus the time of the grocery in this
case it's 19
minus 11. we just figured that out 19
minus 11 is eight so her time
babysitting she spent eight hours
babysitting
and we are done they both add up to 19
and you can make sure that they also
verify that also works out for the
second equation